grenoble vient de se doter
officiellement d'une piste cyclable de 1
km 200 cela porte à cinq kilomètres la
zone réservée aux adeptes de la petite
reine 1977
les grenoblois inaugure en fanfare une
nouvelle piste cyclable à l'époque en
france ce type d'aménagement est très
rare et grenoble fait alors figure de
ville pionnière
il n'y a plus de proches oublier que
cette piste va se poursuivre jusqu'à ce
que nous appelons la rue les en jour
hélas elle rejoindra une autre piste qui
ira vers le coeur de ville en passant
par derrière le stade de glace
l'aboutissement à grenoble de plusieurs
années de revendications dès le début
des années soixante dix les associations
de cyclistes réclamait plus de place et
de sécurité dans la ville
et l'on pouvait lire ou au hasard des
banderoles et des pancartes de
revendications assez curieuse par
exemple assez d'autoroute à sept
parkings des vélos pas d'auto un slogan
en réaction à la politique toute auto
prônée par le président pompidou depuis
la fin des années 60 et il résonnait
aussi dans d'autres villes françaises
exemple ici à paris en 1972 après cette
manifestation pour protester contre l'
l'abondance des voitures dans paris
d'un point de vue circulation pollution
malgré la pression des usagers les
pistes cyclables se met timidement en
place en france
ces aménagements coûte cher aux
municipalités et seules celles avec une
politique écologique forte sont prêtes à
investir strasbourg en faisait partie
en 1978 elle comptait aussi parmi les
villes pionnières
la communauté urbaine a donc voté un
budget considérable 27 millions de
francs à l'aménagement d'un véritable
réseau de pistes cyclables strasbourg
veut être en ce domaine agglomérations
pilotes strasbourg et grenoble sont
encore aujourd'hui des villes référence
en matière d'aménagements cyclables
plusieurs villes françaises ont font
aussi un enjeu majeur en période
d'élections municipales ses
infrastructures deviennent même un
argument de campagne
[Musique]